Welcome.
I'm Steve Bright and this
is a course on how race,
poverty,
mental illness,
intellectual disability affect people
in the criminal justice system and
particularly in cases
involving the death penalty.
I want to spend a little time in this
first class talking about what we're going
to cover over the course of this course.
Uh,
and then we're going to look
some at an introductory case,
the case of a Arkansas
versus rookie rector.
Then look at some historical background,
which is going to set us up for looking
at these issues as they come up,
uh,
in the future.
Let me just say it.
The first,
uh,
this class is not about,
the sort of philosophical questions of
whether the Moro or theological questions
of whether the death penalty
is a good idea or not.
Whether it's morally wrong or,
or or not a,
those are very worthwhile inquiries,
but they're not the ones we're
going to make a in this session.
Uh,
this is really going to be a class,
uh,
about,
the challenges of one accused of a crime
who is first poor and the consequences
of poverty is we'll be talking about is
that you have a court appointed lawyer
usually representing you,
uh,
and often deficiencies,
race,
uh,
the fact that a person is a
member of a racial minority,
uh,
and,
the person that is accused or a,
that people of a certain race
are excluded from participation.
Uh,
as I'll talk a little bit more,
uh,
later.
Uh,
and then finally,
as I said,
people who are intellectually disabled
are suffering from mental illnesses,
which present a number of
question in the context,
uh,
of these cases.
Now these issues are present
in almost all criminal cases,
but they come into particularly bright
relief for clear relief in capital cases.
So we're going to look at them
in the context of capital cases,
but they do have broad
applicability to all kinds of cases,
particularly a poor
people accused of crimes.
Uh,
in our legal system.
Hugo black ones road
for the supreme court.
There can be no equal justice when the
kind of trial a person gets depends upon
the amount of money he or she has a,
but of course we know today that that of
course nothing probably counts more in
terms of the kind of justice a person
receives a than how much money they have.
A and in our court system today,
uh,
the criminal courts,
about 90% of the people
accused of crimes are poor.
Uh,
and the consequence of that,
uh,
as we will talk about the
major consequences having
a court appointed lawyer,
uh,
that a person who is accused of a crime
does not choose his or her lawyer,
doesn't go to the leading
criminal defense lawyer in town,
uh,
and sign them up.
Enormously expensive to
have a private lawyer.
As we see in some of these cases in
which people are defended by private
counsel,
uh,
without a lawyer.
Uh,
all of your constitute
without a competent lawyer,
I should say.
All of your constitutional rights,
uh,
mean nothing.
The lawyer is the person that the
client counts on to know the law,
to assert the law,
uh,
to uh,
and do the investigation of the case.
Investigate both the government's case
to see if there really is a prosecution
case against the person.
Also do an independent investigation
of a whatever facts there may be.
So one is completely dependent
upon the lawyer for that,
but we have this problem.
Why would the government,
uh,
that is trying to convict and execute a
person or a fine or in prison or person?
Why is the government going
to pay for a lawyer to defend,
to defeat that very purpose.
But because of course the states are
responsible and I should say 95% of
criminal cases are in the state courts.
We often think about the federal courts,
but most,
uh,
criminal cases are in the state courts,
meaning primarily there before elected
judges and they're handled by elected
prosecutors.
And as we'll see,
those kinds of political considerations
are going to come into play when a
person,
uh,
is,
is facing any kind of criminal charges.
Um,
uh,
finally,
of course,
poverty may have an impact,
uh,
on a person in many other ways.
And we'll talk about that as
well over the course of the term,
how it is that poverty,
someone who grows up in poverty,
who is affected by poverty
and all kinds of ways.
What legal significance,
if any,
uh,
that that may have a race.
Uh,
this is the court house in Jenkins County,
uh,
Georgia.
Uh,
as you can see,
uh,
it's,
quite a memorial to the confederacy and,
uh,
people including black people
who are called for jury duty,
uh,
who come as witnesses.
And of course,
most importantly,
those who come accused of a crime,
uh,
pass by,
this,
uh,
memorial.
If you're in Shreveport,
Louisiana,
you pass by a this
memorial and Keto perish.
That's the courthouse.
Now,
there's been some complaints
about this monument,
which ultimately resulted in the
confederate flag being taken down,
uh,
but still this huge
monument to the confederacy,
uh,
stands outside the courthouse where every
person coming in to do business in the
court,
uh,
walks past it with the
statutes of Robert E.
Lee and stonewall Jackson.
And other confederate heroes.
Uh,
the courts are the institutions that
have been least affected by the civil
rights movement and the
part of the country where I
have spent the last 30 years
practicing law.
I see a lot of changes.
Uh,
I see African Americans on city councils
and the state legislatures and mayor of
Atlanta of course,
and other places.
But when I go into the courts,
nothing's changed.
I come into the court,
the judges,
white people at the
prosecution table or White,
uh,
the court appointed
lawyers are usually white.
And even in communities that have 25,
30% African American populations,
you look in the jury box and
every one of the jurors is white.
Uh,
all the only person of color who's
going to be before the rail there in the
front of the courtroom is
going to be the person accused.
And we're going to talk about,
uh,
what the dynamics are.
A,
when that happens,
uh,
race influences everything.
Uh,
in the criminal justice system,
we know that a person of color is more
likely to be stopped by the police.
The,
so called driving while
black or driving while Brown,
uh,
we know that during that stop,
they're more likely to be abused.
That is,
they may have a gun pulled on them,
they may be put in handcuffs,
they may be thrown to the ground,
uh,
they're more likely to be arrested,
at the end of that stop.
And this continues all the way through,
more likely,
uh,
to be sent to jail instead
of put on probation in a,
in a,
in a first offender case,
uh,
and all the way through to the severity
of the sentence that is imposed.
I want later in this session
to look at the history,
uh,
that the criminal courts have played,
with regard to racial oppression.
Uh,
because this backdrop
can't just be ignored.
The,
the slavery,
the failure after the civil
war of the criminal courts,
the courts generally,
uh,
to provide equal protection.
That is to protect the freed slaves from
the Klu Klux Klan and the riders and,
and,
and other people,
uh,
convict leasing,
which,
uh,
a lot of people don't even know about,
but which really perpetuated slavery by
arresting people and leasing them out to
plantations and railroads and so forth
really perpetuated slavery all the way up
until about 1940,
uh,
Jim Crow Justice,
which we will talk a
little bit about later.
Uh,
and of course today mass incarceration,
uh,
all of these things have a tremendous
impact with regard to race and,
and on African Americans,
Latinos and other people.
So we want to examine how it is
that that happens in particularly,
uh,
in,
in depth senses.
Uh,
how does one identify racial prejudice?
We're going to look at who
makes discretionary decisions.
Uh,
are there any limits?
Are there any guidelines when a prosecutor
decides whether to seek the death
penalty or not?
Are there any restrictions on that?
Uh,
does anyone review that decision?
Can that one person make a decision
all by him or herself and not have it
reviewed?
Or is that going to be a reviewed?
If we find discrimination,
if we find people who are being
excluded from juries because of race,
uh,
if we find that people are being
prosecuted and race is a factor,
is there a remedy for it?
And the law,
we're always asking not
only what's the injury,
uh,
but what's the remedy for that injury
and then is the remedy adequate?
And one of the things we'll look at in
the class has been a number of remedies,
uh,
that fall far short of accomplishing
what we would hope they would,
uh,
with regard to race.
Uh,
we'll also talk about
mental illness and limited,
uh,
or,
limited intellectual functioning
or intellectual disability.
Uh,
largest mental institution in any
community is the local prison or jail.
And there are a number of issues
that will arise out of mental,
uh,
issues that come out and in,
in other kinds of criminal cases,
but particularly dramatically
sometimes in capital cases.
Uh,
is the person,
um,
uh,
was the person saying at
the time of the crime,
do they understand why they committed?
Are they competent for trial?
Can they work with a lawyer
and participate in trial?
A,
are they a future dangerous?
This is a reason for imposing
the death penalty in many states.
Is the person a future
danger to the community?
And we really asking there is this
person so mentally impaired that we treat
that person because we don't hold them
to the same degree of culpability that we
would hold someone who's not mentally
impaired or do we kill that person because
they're so dangerous?
Uh,
which is,
uh,
somewhat of an eye of
the beholder question.
Uh,
we'll see how that comes
up in death penalty cases,
mitigating factors.
Also a death penalty cases,
uh,
are things about the life
and back in the middle,
uh,
illness,
the mental limitations of a person,
something we take into account.
And if so,
how in deciding to sentence
competency to waive appeal,
sometimes people who are sentenced to
death decide they don't want to appeal,
they give up their appeals and,
and they're executed.
Uh,
are they mentally competent
to make that decision?
Uh,
or uh,
should,
uh,
should the courts not allow that?
And then finally
competency to be executed.
The courts have held it before
somebody can be executed.
And we see this in the Ricky rector case,
which we'll talk about in a moment.
Uh,
the question of does that person
understand why they're being put to death?
Uh,
and so all of these
issues will be taking up.
Uh,
and then we have the question,
even those without,
and this particularly in capital cases,
even those people without a diagnosable
melanomas maybe profoundly damaged,
uh,
in terms of,
of their view of the world and so forth
because they'd been physically abused,
sexually abused,
psychologically abused.
They've lived in a,
uh,
grew up basically in a war zone,
maybe within their home
domestically because there
was so much violence maybe in
their community,
uh,
because there was a lot of violence,
maybe a person that's been injured
even before they were born because the
mother,
uh,
ingested alcohol during the pregnancy.
And so they have fetal alcohol syndrome.
And so that affects the
way their brain works.
And so how does that come into play,
particularly when we come to
the question of sentencing?
Uh,
and then we'll talk some about what are
the challenges of representing someone,
uh,
who may have any of these
disabilities that I've talked about.
How do we tell their story?
Uh,
it's very complicated in these cases
and the death penalty cases because the
people of course are accused
of very serious crimes.
Uh,
this is not question like who's denied
going to school or who's denied being
able to live in a certain
place just because their race.
Race certainly plays a factor here.
And as a,
as we will see a very important factor,
but also there's always going to be
the argument this person committed.
And particularly in the capital cases,
this person committed a heinous crime,
a terrible crime.
Uh,
and so often these cases,
and one of the challenges these cases
is so often they're caught up in the
passions of the moment.
Uh,
and often,
uh,
we don't function our best
when we're caught up in the,
in the passions of the moment.
And we don't always make
the sound is decisions.
Um,
so,
uh,
we'll also examine,
the death penalty,
which was declared
unconstitutional in 1982.
We'll take that up in the next session.
Uh,
but then just four years later,
the supreme court upheld the death toll.
And so we'll look at the
death penalty and what,
uh,
the court says is required to have
a constitutional death penalty.
What people can and cannot
be sentenced to death,
children,
people with intellectual disabilities.
Uh,
those sorts of questions.
And then what kind of
procedures are required,
uh,
for a death penalty case.
Uh,
and then we'll look at
the different people,
uh,
who play a role in this system,
the prosecutor and the
discretion exercised by the
prosecutor and seeking the
death penalty and deciding whether or
not to resolve cases with plea bargains.
Most cases are,
and most death point cases are
resolved with plea bargains,
not with trials.
So we'll explore that.
Uh,
we're talking about the judges
and the role that judges play,
particularly judges who are elected,
uh,
and who have to stand for election every
four or six years and how that might
influence the way they look upon cases
and how they decide legal issues.
Because some decisions in death
penalty cases if cost judges,
uh,
their jobs.
Uh,
we'll look also at the
role of the defense lawyer,
uh,
and what,
how the quality of representation provided
to a poor person accused of crime.
The resources available to that lawyer,
the ability of that lawyer to mount
a defense on behalf of that person.
And then we'll look at the way jury's
function and other aspects of this system.
Uh,
as we,
as we go,
when we look at these legal issues,
we want to think about what law applies,
what constitutional provision are we
talking about that we say governs this
particular issue,
what legal standards
that does it establish.
And,
and,
and we'll,
we'll go into that with
regard to different subjects.
But basically we're asking what must
a party prove in order to prevail?
Either what must the prosecution
prove in order to prevail?
Or what must the defense
prove in order to,
to when it's motion,
uh,
who has the burden of proof and
what is that burden of proof,
uh,
and then what evidence is needed,
to,
uh,
provide,
to satisfy the burden of proof,
uh,
that has established,
we'll deal with this in more detail as
we deal with each of these subjects,
but basically it gives you just some sense
of how we want to look at these legal
issues,
uh,
during,
during the course.
Um,
I want to talk just a minute
generally about sentencing,
uh,
because one of the questions that
we're going to ask in this course is,
uh,
what is sentencing based upon?
What are the objectives of sentencing
people to death or not sensing people to
death?
Uh,
and how important is
consistency in sentencing?
Uh,
if you look at the reasons
people give for sentencing,
one most primarily incapacitation
that we want to take people out of the
society,
lock them up so that society is protected
from any future danger sacks by that
person to Terrance both
to turn the individual,
which is certainly a achieved by
executing a person or putting a person in
prison without any possibility of parole.
But general deterrents,
a very controversial subject,
whether or not having the death penalty,
uh,
or other a very severe punishments,
has a general effect of deterring
people from committing crimes.
Uh,
at one point,
rehabilitation,
uh,
was seen as a major goal of sentencing.
But today we have so many people in prison
and such limited prison budgets that,
uh,
rehabilitation has fallen
far down on the list.
Probably much higher
should be retribution.
A person gets there,
just results.
Uh,
in terms of a,
you did this crime,
uh,
here's what you do to pay for that crime.
The others keep people off the streets,
those kind of a rounding up the homeless
people and all that other ways in which
the criminal law is used.
Uh,
in other objectives that it has.
but then the question,
who decides who decides what objective
we're seeking here and how to go about
it?
Theoretically,
it's at the start,
at least it's legislators because they're
going to decide what laws to pass.
They're going to decide
what punishments to,
uh,
provide for those laws.
Uh,
some legislature,
17,
do not provide for the
death penalty at all.
Uh,
the others,
uh,
do provide for the death pony,
also a mandatory minimums.
So life imprisonment without parole.
These are all sentences
of the legislature,
uh,
may adopt.
Uh,
the prosecutor has a great deal of
discretion in deciding which laws are we
going to enforce,
how rigorously are we going
to enforce those laws?
And we'll talk about that more
when we come to prosecution.
Uh,
what sentence is to seek both through
trials and through plea negotiations,
tremendous amount of power vested in the
prosecutor with regard to how cases are
resolved.
Uh,
and the judge,
how much discretion does the judge have?
We'll talk about judges,
as I said earlier.
Uh,
and then we'll talk about juries
and how juries are selected.
Uh,
and have a go about their decision making.
But we realize that all this,
that the legislature may have one purpose,
uh,
in passing a sentencing law,
the prosecutor may have
a different purpose,
uh,
in deciding what punishment
to seek in a case.
Uh,
and then the judge may have or
the jury may have yet another.
And so if we have all
these competing things,
for example,
we have a judge who
believes in rehabilitation.
This judge is going to be a more lenient
sentence or perhaps where's the judge
in the next courtroom,
uh,
is a strong believer in retribution,
old strong believer in
protecting the community.
So that judge is going to be much more
likely to impose a prison sentence and a
severe prison sentence.
We're going to see the same
thing with regard to communities.
Some communities as we
will talk about later,
uh,
much more likely to impose
the death penalty than others.
Uh,
and,
and much of it has to do with how
the community and the culture there,
uh,
sees the purpose of sentencing,
and how it should be dealt with,
um,
factors to consider.
What do we take into account when
we're deciding how to sentence people?
Uh,
we obviously look at the crime,
uh,
the community.
I don't think there's much
question about these injuries,
uh,
that,
are,
are the result,
a injury to the person,
to the community,
the heinousness of the crime,
the,
uh,
and then the question,
how much do we look to the
desires of the victims,
uh,
with regard to deciding?
And then we look at some things
with regard to the defendant,
what,
what's the defendant's prior record?
Almost always going to be accounted for.
Maybe age is going to be accounted for,
but then do we get into things
like mental limitations is,
I was discussing earlier a
potential for rehabilitation,
adjustment to prison,
a lot of controversy about what kinds
of factors are to be considered.
And then of course,
also the question of does race,
class politics,
other extraneous factors,
non extrovert,
I guess I can call extra legal factors.
Not legal reasons for imposing
a particular punishment.
But do they come into play as well?
And we'll see very often,
uh,
they do.